how would you summarize today so far now  prague um yeah this game  um i think i got a very big advantage  out of the opening and i was going up  i mean i got a queen so  yeah i think this was smooth game  how much does it actually do for your  confidence as a chess player to see that  you are  more than able to keep track with the  best players in the world yeah um  it definitely gives me confidence and i  believe  um i'm kind of underrated in classical  chess i think  um if i play more tournaments i will get  more ratings so  i think it should be up there what is  your correct rating  i don't know  good luck in this match right now  because you're doing very well prank  yeah thanks